tucks away amid the sweeping moorlands
and giant talls of Dartmoor is something
very rare we're coming to the end of the
meadow now and we're just walking into
the rainforest hidden out of sight
Atlantic Woodland our answer to a
rainforest thrives there are no monkeys
swinging from trees but there is a
carbon trapping habitat-rich environment
we are in a temperate rainforest most
people have heard of tropical
rainforests like the Amazon the Congo in
Indonesia not so many people have heard
temp about temperate rainforest and why
it's a rainforest is because of the
constant high humidity and for most of
the year not today but for the most the
year very high rainfall and because of
that you don't just see trees you see
all sorts of things growing on trees so
all around us you can you can hear the
water bubbling away but every Branch
every twig you see has got Moss and
lichen growing on it
centuries of Woodland removal and
intensive agriculture have seen a huge
reduction in forests like this dense
Lush rainforest like this used to cover
around a fifth of the UK it's now
understood to be less than one percent
it's why the Devon Wildlife trust is
about to start planting a whole new one
well the outskirts of top Ness Harry and
his team will be transforming this old
Farmland into temperate rainforest
planting clusters of Oak Birch Willow
and Hazel it will take hundreds of years
and the trust says British rainforests
will cope well with our changing climate
we have to bear in mind that while
climate is changing a lot of these
forces droughts disease and things like
that they have happened in our landscape
before and most of the Native species
are quite well adapted so if we give
nature a helping hand but let nature
lead us then I think we have the best
chances of seeing this Forest survive
and thrive
the rainforest will go alongside a new
self-sufficient community on the farm
including regenerative farming and more
than 40 Eco homes the concept is that
human development doesn't necessarily
have to be negative for
um the planet we kind of I think humans
live with this sort of idea that
development is always bad but if it's
done if it's designed really really well
and carefully then it can actually have
positive impacts in terms of
biodiversity the reintroduction of
rainforest to Devon follows similar
projects in North Wales and the Isle of
Man thanks to a 38 million pound fund
from Aviva even though it will take
centuries to create environments as rich
as this it is the latest step to protect
and enhance Britain's diverse
Countryside
damn white it's Sky News in South Devon